dietmar wischmeyer sagt leise servus zum
klimaschutz lieber klimaschutz
du wirst uns fehlen ermordet von einem
wütenden orangenen man mit einem
kugelschreiber mehr braucht es nicht in
das klimaabkommen von paris kann man
jetzt nur noch einen toten fisch
entwickeln alles weil donald tsang
fossile brennstoffe liebt verkleidet
sich sogar gerne als bergmann mit
schaufelt unsichtbare kohle
das ist das faszinierende an ihm typen
er kann alles tragen er sieht immer aus
wie ein vollidiot
wer weiß vielleicht sogar recht und die
chinesen haben sich den ganzen
klimawandel nur ausgedacht genau wie den
nordpol
wenn als schließlich auch der
weihnachtsmann erfunden der guten alten
kohle ist furchtbares unrecht geschehen
aber das ist jetzt vorbei ende den krieg
gegen die kohleindustrie clean coal
saubere kohle
das macht ungefähr so viel sehen vegane
blutwurst oder lustiger münster tatort
weil ja auch deutschland weiter auf
kohle setzt im letzten jahr wieder
deutlich mehr co2 rausgehauen hat wende
ich mich direkt an einen fiktiven enkel
von justin bieber von justin ich weiß du
bist jetzt sauer wegen weltuntergang und
so ist irgendwie eine scheiße du die
ausgesucht hast für dein leben
vielleicht ist es die rein groß dass ich
immer viel spaß aber mit meinen autos
dann kannst du auch mal andersherum
sehen was hat deine generation denn
jeweils für mich getan
er findet halt irgendwas oder fliegt zum
neuen planeten keine ahnung also auf zu
heulen und wird man kreativ werden
schwimmen lasse team wacken oder noch
besser schick einen terminator in der
zeit zurück und der r schießt dann die
mutter von donald trump gar nicht so
schwer sagt meister von star wars
mit moritz meyer vergleich zum
klimaschutz
[Applaus]